whissell l'arrestation de sept membres
du gia le mouvement islamiste algérien
le dernier d'entre eux après un assaut
donné par la police
ces sommes pourraient être mêlés aux
attentats de l'été 95 en france elle
s'appelle marguerite c'est le premier
mot femelle clonée dans notre pays par
les spécialistes de l'inra et des nez il
ya quinze jours elle pèse 48 look trop
de bruit dominique voynet lance un plan
de suppression de 2600 points noirs sont
prévues des aides à l'insonorisation
mais aussi une chasse aux discothèques
des plus bruyants l'économie chinoise en
pleine mutation dans ce pays d'un
milliard et demi d'habitants bon nombre
d'entreprises d'état sont à vendre avec
leur personnel et 8 millions de
fonctionnaires dont perdre leur emploi
régionales le débat de ce soir dominique
strauss kahn le ministre de l'économie
et des finances face alain madelin voilà
monsieur bonsoir toute la journée un
quartier de bruxelles est restée bouclée
par les forces de police
tout a commencé ce matin à l'aube
lorsque les forces spéciales ont voulu
arrêter un groupe de sept hommes membres
présumés des réseaux islamistes du gia
algérien six d'entre eux ont été arrêtés
sont trop de résistance
un septième s'est retranché dans un
immeuble puissamment armés ce soir les
policiers ont donné l'assaut l'homme a
été à son tour arrêté ce groupe
recherchait depuis de longs mois
seraient mêlés aux attentats meurtriers
de l'été 95 en france on porte à jarno
boutet à la praille
il est 18h15 les gendarmes viennent de
donner l'assaut farid mellouk se rend et
quittent l'immeuble caché par une
couverture
depuis 5 heures ce matin ce membre
présumé du gia s'étaient retranchés au
dernier étage avec des fusils
kalachnikov et des grenades
il menaçait de tout faire sauter les
forces de l'ordre ont fait route à
infiltrer des gaz dans la pièce où il
était retranché et de lui même le
forcené est sorti et il a été assez
intercepté dans les escaliers en voulant
quitter la maison les complices de
mellouk six hommes arrêtés ce matin à la
même adresse d islamiste d'origine
algérienne que les gendarmes filets
depuis plusieurs mois pour trafic de
faux papiers
tous sont membres présumés du gia safer
été mise à l'instruction déjà au mois de
janvier et les éléments plus précis ne
faut pas arriver il ya quinze jours dans
l'avant dernière semaine du mois de
février
mais le cas de farine mellouk intéresse
de très près les autorités françaises
qui avaient perdu sa trace
il est français il a 32 ans la justice
l'a déjà jugé par défaut et condamné le
18 février dernier à sept ans
d'emprisonnement pour relation avec une
entreprise terroriste
c'était le procès dit de
chasse-sur-rhône farine mais loupe
accusés d'avoir apporté un soutien
logistique aux gia pendant les attentats
de l'été 1995 en france
aujourd'hui les autorités belges ont
arrêté en huitièmes dans un autre
quartier de bruxelles
elle se félicite de ces résultats espère
que la belgique ne sera plus considérée
comme une base arrière pour d'autres
membres présumés du gia et à l'instant
même le ministre de l'intérieur au belge
fait savoir que les membres du gia
présumé du jet a arrêté aujourd'hui sont
des hauts responsables de l'organisation
islamiste
l'opération menée aujourd'hui est
l'aboutissement de plusieurs mois
d'enquêté de filature par la police
belge en liaison avec d'autres polices
d'europe
cette opération est la plus importante
jamais menée à ce jour sur le territoire
européen
la belgique comme l'allemagne
l'angleterre sont souvent présentés
comme des refuges pour ces groupes
terroristes venus d'algérie et dont le
terrain d'action et principalement la
france pense aux jeunes sympathisants du
gia est pourtant bien connue des
services de sécurité belges avec maroufi
dans cet appartement de bruxelles ne
cache pas ses opinions
le groupe islamique armé est une bonne
réponse
un région plusieurs lieux de il y a
trois ans déjà la belgique démonter l'un
des premiers réseaux de soutien
logistique aux groupes islamiques armés
ici rue du bruch la belgique mais
surtout la france de douter des attentes
à la sûreté de l'état belge
photographiera cet homme à bruxelles ali
touchante
il sera identifié plus tard comme le
cerveau présumé des attentats de l'été
1995 à paris à bruxelles où circuler
comme dans la capitale française
ces cassettes de propagande du gia où
l'on expliqué la fabrication de bombes
artisanales
ce matin la gendarmerie belge s'est
retrouvé selon nos informations passent
à un groupe du gia qui s'est reconstitué
en liaison avec un émir d'al chef en
algérie qui se fait appeler la tap
ce groupe est constitué d'activistes
tunisiens venus de france ou encore de
suède et du danemark
ces hommes étaient sous surveillance
depuis plusieurs semaines et c'est la
crainte que la préparation de nouveaux
attentats cette fois s'il peut être lié
à la coupe du monde de football à paris
qui a précipité l'opération des
autorités belges
c'est à peine pensable ce qui s'est
passé hier à pavilly dans la banlieue de
rouen une épicière de 60 ans a été
retrouvé assassiné tué d'un coup de
revolver un 357 magnum une balle tirée
en pleine tête
les trois meurtriers présumés des gamins
entre 14 et 15 ans l'un d'entre eux
s'est livrée l'après midi même à la
police
les deux autres ont été interpellées
quelques temps après reportage vincent
nguyen et christophe et les quelques
6000 habitants de pavilly se croyait
bien loin de la violence urbaine des
grandes agglomérations
et pourtant l'épicerie tabac de la rue
sigfried est fermé la porte scellée par
la gendarmerie hier midi trois jeunes
sont entrés encagoulés dans la boutique
après s'être assurée que l'épicière
était seule la menaçant d'un 357 magnum
il lui demande
tenue de la caisse à peine 1000 font
peut-être la femme at-elle résisté
elle est tuée d'une balle de 9 mm les
jeunes s'enfuient sans même emporter le
butin
ils ont entre 14 et 15 ans je crois que
c'est parce qu'il fait plus mal au coeur
plus avoir causé des enfants qui sont
dans le quartier qu'ils sont
je sais pas incompréhension dans un
quartier pas spécialement difficile
alexandre grégory et julien ne sont pas
issus d'un milieu très défavorisé
on leur cherche un mobile peut-être la
drogue à votre avis pourquoi il ya
pourquoi il a essayé de faire ça c'est
vrai que ça secrète que le synep aux
personnes sur tout le monde sait bien
qu'il ya un gros trafic de drogue sur la
vierge
ça c'est sûr qu'est ce que je tombe
encore plus bex et des enfants étaient
déjà au courant avant que ça se passe
que mais puisque vous allez braqueurs je
trouve que leur avait parlé mais lui il
croyait que c'était quoi rigoler quoi
l'un des agresseurs s'est rendue les
deux autres ont été interpellées
ils sont en garde à vue les enquêteurs
cherchent à déterminer si l'auteur du
coup de feu a tiré accidentellement ou
non on sait que le 357 magnum
appartenait à son beau-père une arme
détenues légalement mais qui aurait dû
être démonté et surtout tenu hors
d'atteinte
et de deux pour les habitants de dugny
en banlieue parisienne après la bombe du
mois de décembre un autre engin explosif
d'attendre la deuxième guerre mondiale a
été désamorcée aujourd'hui mais les
artificiers ont dû cette fois ci la
faire exploser
aucun dégât toutes les précautions
avaient été prises et la population
évacue assez de bruit trop de bruit pour
lutter contre la pollution sonore le
ministre de l'environnement annonce un
premier plan de suppression de 2600
points noirs des aides vont être
accordées pour insonoriser des logements
et pour ce qui concerne les troubles du
voisinage un décret va être publié
limitant le niveau sonore des lieux
privés et publics diffusant de la
musique les discothèques sont donc les
premières visées reportage au rang le
job
jean paul-lemieux temps
dominique juin et le patron du fogny
galles un des hauts lieux de la nuit à
paris
il y a deux ans à la suite d'une
pétition de riverains il a dû faire des
travaux une vitre esprit qui a été
imposé par les praticiens qui est
d'ailleurs même été mis en billets
esprits pour pouvoir casser le sont au
tout ce moment tout ce qui est plafond
tout ce qui structure
donc daily mail on a injecté de l'amour
aussi bien aux couples à fond que sur
les côtés sur son sol en tout 600 mille
francs d'aménagement pour limiter le
bruit et malgré cela la nuisance sonore
est encore mal vécue et donne lieu à des
plaintes régulières téléphone alors il
peut très bien faire téléphoner sans
laisser non sans rien qui téléphonent au
commissariat d'arrondissement et les
policiers se déplacent et pour ça depuis
à dévoyer bon bah c'est logique qu'elle
disposait quand même donc y consacraient
des voiliers et désormais avec le décret
voynet il y aura une limite légale à ne
pas franchir 105 décibels à l'intérieur
de la discothèque et contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait penser les patrons de
boîtes de nuit vois plutôt ça d'un bon
oeil on pourra apprendre arrive à des
fermetures administratives quelquefois
arbitraire puisque les mesures ne sont
pas faites et on ferme des
établissements quand il ya une
plaignante
on ne pourra avant d'arriver à des
fermetures administratives et je
l'espère on va appuyer leur sens la voir
faire une enquête pour voir si la
véritable noir nuisances constatées
cette mesure n'est pas anodine elle
concerne 4000 établissements en zone
urbaine un million de personnes
souffriraient de leurs nuisances sonores
parmi les mesures de lutte contre
l'exclusion annoncée hier par le
gouvernement l'une d'entre elles
concernant le logement mérite une
explication plus détaillée il s'agit de
la taxation des propriétaires
d'appartements ou de logements vacants
au 1er janvier 99
sont visés les propriétaires privés et
les institutionnels principalement
banques et assurances gens payent eux
jean-paul miauton dans le centre-ville
de mantes-la-jolie un petit immeuble qui
rassemble trois logements et une
boutique un des logements étaient vides
depuis quelques mois son propriétaire
valeureux loué il sait faire pour cela
des travaux dont une partie est
subventionné par un organisme public
spécialisé un autre immeuble en ville le
même propriétaire y possède un studio
qu'il laisse vite dit il
en attendant le locataire qui paiera dès
1900 francs demandés dans un an ce
logement s'il reste vide sans attaque
c'est ce qui bien sûr ne fait pas
plaisir aux propriétaires s'il existe
une tête d'une habitation c'est
encouragera
propriétaire qui actuellement sont dans
le doute de savoir s'ils veulent garder
leur logement ou pas de s'en débarrasser
et je crois que avec des lois comme ça
on diminuera le nombre des propriétaires
bailleurs alors que j'avais cru
comprendre que le ministre voulait créer
justement des nouveaux propriétaires
bailleurs je pense qu'on fait les choses
à l'envers
la taxe frappant les logements vides
s'appliquera seulement dans les zones où
existe une forte demande de logements
comme ici en ile de france
quant à son montant il sera basé sur la
valeur locative du logement 10% par
exemple la première année les gros
propriétaires assurances et banques ne
s'estime pas viser nos logements restent
vides distille le temps de les
rafraîchir on les relous dans les trois
mois
certains pourtant ne rejoue pas les
logements au fur et à mesure du départ
des locataires
objectif vendre l'immeuble totalement
vide et en tirer ainsi le plus grand
bénéfice
la taxe jouera pour eux comme pour cet
immeuble dont les logements sont vides
depuis plus de deux ans satisfaction en
tout cas des associations de défense des
mal-logés
globalement c'est un bon dispositif que
nous on défende déjà depuis plusieurs
années on a 7 ans n'est satisfait
aujourd'hui de voir une de voir mises en
oeuvre par contre on aurait souhaité que
les bailleurs sociaux les collectivités
territoriales soit également soumises à
cette taxe la taxe devrait rapporter 200
millions de francs par an elle aidera à
la rénovation des logements locatifs la
france à son premier clown animal
marguerite un veau femelle de 48 kg né
le 21 février dernier dans les
laboratoires de l'institut national de
la recherche agronomique marguerie se
porte très bien jean daniel flaysakier
dominique bonnet entre deux bouchées de
foin les vaches de la ferme
expérimentale de l'inra n'avait cet
après midi qu'un seul sujet de
discussion
marguerite née comme une fleur le 20
février
marguerite conçu sans spermatozoïdes un
veau femelle clonée
tout est parti d'un foetus de vaud de 60
jours sur lequel on a prélevé des
cellules censé n'être capable de
fabriquer que du muscle l'ovule d'une
vache a été vidé de son noyau
on y ami celui de la cellule musculaire
voici d'ailleurs sous le microscope
comment cela s'est vraiment passé le
noyau de la cellule musculaire et déposé
et là surprise la grossesse des buts
cellule puis 4 8 16 un embryon qui se
forment un embryon convard et implanté
dans une vache porteuse et neuf mois
plus tard sans via marguerie clown est
ainsi des animaux va permettre de faire
progresser très rapidement la mise au
point de divers traitements
les clones peuvent être des modèles
intéressants parce que quand on a
plusieurs animaux qui ont le même front
génétique l'un des animaux peut être
utilisé comme témoin et les autres
animaux servir à l'expérimentation et ça
permet en même temps de réduire dans dé
façon importante le nombre d'animaux
nécessaire et bientôt à côté des les
tirs traditionnel il y aura des vaches
clonées qui extrait de prendre le relais
des substances destinées à faire des
médicaments et qui sait un jour
peut-être grâce au clonage
on verra à naître les gars sont dans les
choux et les petites marguerites dans
les roses
après le président de la république et
les principaux leaders politiques c'est
le premier ministre qui a parcouru
aujourd'hui les allées du salon de
l'agriculture se voulant rassurante pour
les organisations syndicales agricoles
ils réagissent pas déclaré qu'en l'état
actuel la réforme de la politique
agricole commune n'était pas acceptable
par la france dans la mesure où elle ne
prend pas suffisamment en compte la
diversité du monde et des productions
agri à une semaine et demi maintenant
des élections régionales la gauche
s'organise en ce moment même au zénith à
paris une grande réunion publique au
cours de laquelle d'ailleurs le premier
ministre doit prendre la parole ce soir
guilaine chenu patrick delbac à une
campagne tout à l'économie et aux
symboles
à dix jours des régionales le premier
ministre entre en scène entourée des
leaders de sa majorité plurielle
le nail jospin ne participera qu'à deux
meetings pour montrer qu'il continue de
gouverner pendant que ses amis font
campagne cinq parties réunies une mise
en scène âprement négociée depuis des
semaines le socialiste jean christophe
cambadélis en est l'artisan les places
l'ordre et la durée des interventions
tout est calculé
neuf mois après la victoire de la gauche
et au moment où les sondages deviennent
favorables
la tentation est grande de faire de ces
élections un test national de région 122
à gauche
telles sont quelques-unes bascule du bon
côté il faut que s'est passé l'année
dernière en législatif fois confirmé
renforcée pour qu'on puisse enfin
travailler un premier meeting à paris le
choix de l'île de france n'est pas un
hasard la gauche en a fait le symbole de
ces espoirs de reconquête
je ne fais pas de troisième tour
d'élection deux précédents tours de la
suivante ce que ça ne m'intéresse pas je
vais gagner ces régionales et je veux
paris tombe à gauche demain charles
pasqua l'a dit à l'envers si la région
et de france passe à gauche c'est un
tremblement de terre pour les hongrois
les privilèges
c'est au bout d'une région view la porte
de l'espoir donc un grand ben moi je
crois que les gens le ressentent comme
ça lionel jospin va ce soir décliné de
bilan de son gouvernement
selon lui c'est le meilleur argument de
campagne de la gauche pour ces
régionales dernier sondage en date type
soc le point paraître demain au niveau
national la gauche l'emporterait avec
39% des suffrages l'udf rpr en
recueillerait 32 et le front national 14
le front national qui connaît pour la
première fois de son histoire de
véritables remous intérieurs très
sérieux jean marie le pen est contestée
par des militants de base par certains
membres de l'appareil mais aussi pas un
au moins de ses plus fidèles soutiens
jean jacques gérard d'un inconnu du
grand public
c'est un intime du président du front
national aujourd'hui se met en congé du
parti il estime que rien ne va plus à
l'intérieur du front il demande même à
son ami jean marie le pen de penser à sa
succession reportage michaël darmon
patrick démunis le colonel jean jacques
girardin est un compagnon de route de
jean-marie le pen conseiller régional
front national depuis 1986 cet ancien
gendarme a passé huit ans dans les
coulisses du pouvoir à l'elysée à la
tête de la gare de la présidence de la
république intime de jean marie le pen
membres de son cabinet le colonel
gérardin reçoit depuis plusieurs mois
dans sa maison du var des appels de
militants et de cadres du parti à
travers ses écrits ou ses coups de
téléphone
il y avait véritablement des dérapages
dans tous les départements que la
commission des investitures avait
investi un peu n'importe qui est mis sur
la touche les gens sont respectables qui
avait fait le front national qui étaient
des militants de base influents parmi
les militaires d'activé et de réserve
dans le vin
le colonel gérardin de guerre lasse
décide alors de se mettre en congé du
front national il va toujours écouté
avec beaucoup de bienveillance en
opinant quelquefois en disant oui tu as
raison etc
et puis les décisions n'ont pas été
prises alors est ce que c'est parce que
c'est grave ce que je vais dire est ce
que c'est parce que c'est un homme qui
n'est pas capable de prendre une
décision et c'est ce qui fait qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui disent il faudrait
peut-être que jean marie le pen tout en
conservant la la présidence du front
national pense à désigner un dauphin et
et pense à sa succession en car dans la
vie les pages se tournent cette fronde
ne se limite pas au seul département du
var rétracter publication de dissidents
circuit dans le parti et sur toute la
côte d'azur
il illustre l'ampleur de la contestation
interne et à chaque fois le pen est
critiquée à nice cet ancien candidat fn
aux législatives mène la bataille au
sein de la fédération des
alpes-maritimes
lui estime que jean marie le pen
aujourd'hui desserts sont partis parce
qu'il n'y a pas là une volonté de dire
après moi le déluge
est ce qu'il n'ya pas là la volonté
d'écarter toute possibilité pour un
quelconque ux et soeurs
d'accéder au pouvoir que lui n'a pas su
obtenir
jean-marie le pen sait qu'il a du mal à
tenir les siens en provence ces derniers
temps mais en vieux routier de la
politique il attend son résultat aux
élections régionales annoncera peut-être
la fin de l'orage
jean marie le pen qui pour la première
fois aujourd'hui a déclaré en public
qu'il fallait voter pour la droite pour
empêcher que la gauche dispose de tous
les pouvoirs
à propos du front national le livre de
deux nos confrères l'après le pen aux
éditions du seuil
écrit par michaël darmon journaliste à
france 2 et romain rosso de l'express au
procès de maurice papon à bordeaux
l'avocat de la défense m e varaut a
déposé une plainte contre serge
klarsfeld le père d'arnaud classe fait
de l'avocat de la partie civile dans le
procès une plainte en rapport avec les
révélations de m arno klarsfeld sur les
liens de parenté entre le président de
la cour d'assises de bordeaux et une
familles des victimes pour m e varaut il
s'agit d'une tentative de pression sur
la justice
la commission d' enquête sur
l'utilisation des fonds publics en corse
est entrée officiellement en fonction
aujourd'hui elle sera présidée présidé
par le socialiste jean glavany et devra
remettre un rapport d'ici à six mois
en corse les nationalistes
collaborateurs du journal ou ribombu
interpellé hier ont été relâchés
finalement aujourd'hui ils ont été
interrogés dans le cadre toujours de l'
enquête sur le meurtre du préfet claude
erignac
l'actualité internationale alors que
londres et dublin et les organisations
politiques d'irlande du nord tente
péniblement de trouver un accord pour
mettre un terme à 25 années de conflit
la liste des morts s'allonge depuis le
début de l'année 13 ce qui est survenu
aux deux derniers en date à quelque
chose d'émouvant et de désespérant à la
fois dans un petit village tranquille
entre guillemets est bien sûr ce sont
deux amis d'enfance un catholique un
protestant qui ont été abattus en même
temps londres etienne et nantes
ces histoires là finissent toujours
comme ça avec des larmes et avec des
fleurs mais si depuis hier ils pleurent
peut être plus que d'habitude c'est que
le double assassinat commis mardi soir
dans ce petit village ne ressemble pas à
tous les meurtres qui depuis 30 ans
ensanglantent irlande du nord d'amiens
entraîneur était catholique son ami
d'enfance philippe allen était
protestant ensemble comme tous les soirs
il prenait un verre dans leurs pubs deux
hommes armés sont entrés les ont
insultée plaquée à terre et froidement
abattus d'ordinaire si l'on peut dire en
irlande du nord on tue ceux d'en face
ceux de l'autre camp
c'est pour cela qu'aujourd'hui personne
un point de ce pass ne comprend dans
notre village vous ne verrez jamais un
protestant refusé de boire un verre avec
un catholique et l'inversé est aussi
vrai si on pensait vivre à l'écart du
conflit dans un monde différent
est ce qui vient de se passer nous
ramène à la réalité de l'irlande du nord
cette fois ci les soupçons se portent
sur des extrémistes protestants il
n'aurait pas hésité à tuer l'un des
membres de leur communauté
parce que son amitié avec un catholique
représentait trop bien cette
réconciliation que le gouvernement tente
d'imposer ensemble députés catholiques
et protestants de la circonscription
sont venus dire aux familles leurs
émotions et au pays tout entier le
premier ministre a dit sa détermination
est humaine ces deux hommes assassinés
l'autre soir cette amitié au delà de
tout sectarisme symbolise la writer par
leur atroce brutalité représentent eux
le passé reste damian le catholique
philippe le protestant seront enterrés
demain dans leur village en irlande du
nord huit habitants sur dix se disent
persuadés que la marche forcée des
autorités vers un accord de paix est
vouée à l'échec
32 mort de 157 blessés c'est le terrible
bilan d'un attentat suicide qui a eu
lieu dans la capitale du sri lanka
colombo un kamikaze a fait exploser un
minibus dans une des rues les plus
fréquentées du centre ville au beau
milieu d'un embouteillage
deux autocars transportant des écoliers
littéralement exploser des troubles se
poursuivent dans la province serbe du
kosovo les forces serbes utilisant les
grands moyens canon hélicoptère blindé
ont lancé aujourd'hui une attaque contre
une dizaine de villages peuplés
d'habitants d'origine albanaise il y
aurait plusieurs dizaines de morts 22
dit on ce soir officiellement il s'agit
d'une offensive contre les terroristes
qui a eu lieu au moment où l'europe
envoie un émissaire à belgrade en la
personne du ministre des affaires
étrangères monsieur robin cook
il faut se mettre à l'échelle de la
chine un milliard et demi d'habitants un
pays qui se transforme à très grande
vitesse sur le plan économique et qui a
décidé de se séparer
dans un premier temps de 8 millions de
fonctionnaires parallèlement un bon
nombre d' usine d'état aux équipements
dépasser sont à vendre parfois avec leur
personne pékin isabelle bechler
attristant le bras anne tchane toute la
ville toute la vie tourne autour de la
sidérurgie
sur les sept cent mille habitants deux
cent mille 100 salariés dingue
le mastodonte construit dès 1916 par les
japonais des installations forcément
obsolète des technologies dépassées
depuis des décennies comme ces pourra
creuser qui met quatre heures et demie à
produire 300 tonnes d'acier
ici la question ne se pose même pas il
faut des fours à convertisseur comme
celui ci il nécessite moins d'énergie et
produisent plus vite gains de
productivité 60 francs la tonne il y
avait dans cette usine
trois fours à creuser de 300 tonnes
chacun qui consommaient beaucoup et qui
était très polluant depuis un an nous en
avons transformé trois ans convertisseur
de 90 tonnes
le convertisseur est beaucoup plus
efficace et moins coûteux
suivant les directives du 15e congrès du
parti communiste la direction du groupe
a décidé de se recentrer sur son
activité acier de ne garder qu'un quart
des employés soit 50000 toutes les
autres activités périphériques ou
dérivés mines transports logements
hôpitaux sont censés trouver leur
rentabilité dans les trois ans faute de
quoi elles seront purement et simplement
sacrifié
seuls trois usines dont les critères de
productivité sont comparables aux normes
internationales ont été introduites en
bourse pour trouver des capitaux frais
et sortir de la crise
c'est le cas de cette unité de fil de
fer la chaîne est américaine d'occasions
mais le pilotage on a été modernisée et
informatisé sur place depuis que notre
entreprise est cotée en bourse
les ouvriers veulent absolument acheter
des actions maintenant nos employés
sentent que leurs intérêts sont liés à
ceux de l'entreprise et ça les stimule
voilà pour les secteurs performant mais
des pans entiers d'industrie sont
sacrifiés et les salariés avec
officiellement c'est avec indemnités et
formation en fait on conseille aux
futurs chômeurs de se lancer dans le
petit commerce pour s'en sortir
rien n'a été prévu pour nous un jour on
nous a seulement dit rentrez chez vous
vous êtes en vacances les enfants
quelles questions and gagnent vient
d'annoncer à cette mère de famille
qu'elle serait licencié le mois suivant
là nous vous savez on vit au jour le
jour les enfants nous coûte 4 à 5 francs
par jour ça fait 120 francs par mois et
ne de salaire ça représente à peine 180
francs elle mois prochain et sera au
chômage alors la plupart de ces petits
vendeurs sont des chômeurs sans
indemnité c'est trop dur maintenant yak
des chômeurs qu'est-ce que vous voulez
qu'on vende les gens n'ont plus un sou
c'est pas vrai la sidérurgie triomphante
plastronne toujours au centre ville mais
les espoirs des habitants sont bien elie
mais n'allez pas leur parler de l'avenir
radieux de l'acier chinois via de
l'au-delà lui sur la lune non non mais
sur ce soir après les révélations faites
par la sonde américaine lunar prospector
qui a donc trouvé de la lutte de l'eau
pardon je vais y arriver
de l'eau sur la lune sous forme de glace
cette eau sous forme de glace avait déjà
été repérée d'un satellite c'était en
on a donc la confirmation ce soir nous
parlions tout à l'heure du premier essai
de clonage en france c'est une autre
sorte de clonage techniques
scientifiques qui a eu lieu au salon
imagina à monte carlo où l'on a assisté
aux premiers défilés de mannequins
virtuels reconstituer clown et donc une
certaine façon à partir des mouvements
des véritables top model la collection
présentée était celle de thierry mugler
stéphane guez et jean-françois cheveux
voici nous prenons matière numérique une
image de synthèse dont la grâce a
pourtant quelque chose de très humain
car pour créer ce défilé de mode virtuel
les techniciens sont capturées la
démarche chaloupée de christina un vrais
mannequins en chair et en os
c'est ensuite à l'habiller je prends une
robe et je lui je lui mets du coton je
lui mets de la soie et à partir de là je
regarde qu'est ce qui se passe c'est la
robe est adaptée si le mouvement de la
robe qui va se faire en fonction de
personnes qui marchent vite ou lentement
bien c'est toute cette simulation
automatique qui va aujourd'hui donner un
apport fabuleux aux designers tester le
comportement d'un vêtement avant même sa
fabrication une des applications des
clones numériques
six personnages qui marie fluidité du
mouvement humain et beauté de l'image de
synthèse
ils sont partout dans les jeux les films
d'animation les publicités certains
imaginent est même possible de cloner le
visage d'acteur de cinéma
une résultat n'est pour l'instant pas
concluants pour moi lecteur virtuel
c'est pas pour demain
c'est pour après demain c'est vrai
la question que je poserai pas ce qu'il
faut aussi se poser cette question c'est
est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin de faire
un acteur virtuelle dans tous les cas
quoi faire un acteur quand il faut et
quand il joue c'est vivant c'est par byd
abl il ya des choses qu'on peut
qu'on n'atteindra pas il ya la pellicule
elle enregistre plus que
que ce que vont enregistrer les petits
points parfois en attendant de faire
jouer catherine deneuve avec charlie
chaplin les clones numériques peuvent
déjà nous représenter en temps réel sur
les nouveaux réseaux de communication
comme internet un moyen pour donner un
visage un peu plus humain à la machine
c'est l'heure du débat des élections
régionales ce soir arlette chabot alain
duhamel reçoivent dominique strauss kahn
à la maggia merci alors à 11 jours des
élections régionales les français ne
semblent pas encore très mobilisés pour
ce scrutin c'est ce que révèle un
sondage ipsos que publiera demain
l'hebdomadaire le point regarder 60% des
personnes interrogées se déclarent
intéressés par ce scrutin ils étaient 67
pour cent il ya un peu plus d'un mois
deuxième question elle arrive elle l'a
sans doute une ignorance de ce mode de
scrutin puisque 50% des français pensent
qu'il y à deux tours aux régionales
occasion de rappeler qu'il n'y en a
qu'un et c'est bien effectivement le 15
mars
enfin troisième question souhaitez vous
dans votre région une victoire de la
gauche ou de la droite vous voyez la
réponse un avantage pour la gauche alors
alain madelin
au fond vous n'avez peut-être pas
réussis les uns et les autres à
mobiliser beaucoup les français et
notamment l'opposition et bien est-ce
que ce cru qu'elle n'arrive pas un peu
trop tôt pour vous ah je pense que ce
scrutin n'est pas le grand rendez-vous
des examens de passage du gouvernement
et ce scrutin est un scrutin
intermédiaire fin mais j'ai pris
l'habitude de ne pas trop croire les
sondages sort de deux élections on nous
donnait gagnant aux élections
législatives on a perdu les élections
présidentielle jacques chirac était
donné perdant il a gagné dans la version
donc dimanche au nom honni bassam le
dire attendons dimanche
j'observe simplement une chose c'est que
manifestement l'opposition a un problème
avec parce qu'elle est bloquée par le
front national
et on voit au travers de ce sondage et
on le verra dans chacune des régions
un électeur qui hésitent aujourd'hui qui
se dit est-ce que je vais voter pour
l'opposition où est ce que je vais voter
pour le front national pas voter pour le
front national c'est de fait une fois
apporté au socialisme monsieur strauss
kahn ce qui est frappant dans la
description que viendra madelin c'est
qu'un électeur peut hésiter entre le
front national et l'opposition
ce qui montre bien les proximité que
nous dénonçons il ya des proximités ya
des porosités et des hommes qui passent
de l'un à l'autre ça aboutit à ce que
vient de dire à la madeleine électeur
peut hésiter effectivement monsieur
matte l'accord besoin strauss kahn ne
devrais pas dire ça puisque monsieur le
pen aux dernières élections législatives
lui n'avait pas hésité il avait dit je
préfère monsieur jospin à monsieur
chirac comme comment est ce qu'on fait
pour éviter que le front national soit
larbitre concrètement il n'y a rien à
faire
mardi mais là où les choses sont claires
en ce qui nous concerne nous avons dit
il n'y aura pas de compromis il n'y aura
pas d'accord avec le front national
donc il faut que les électrices et
électeurs trouvent confiance dans la
majorité généralement sortante dans les
régions et ils reconduisent c'est
majorité autour de leur projet point
ouija moi je suis de cette solution si
les électeurs sont contents de la
majorité sortante ils votent pour elle
si sont pas contents ils votent pour la
majorité nationale c'est à dire la
gauche et les verts en ile de france par
exemple je pense qu'ils ne sont pas
contents je pense qu'ils changeront
paf et d'avranches m'enfin c'est
possible il ya aucune raison d'aller
voter pour le front national
si on veut éviter que le front national
arbitres il faut faire ce que nous
venons de faire c'est faire voter à
l'assemblée nationale un texte qui
permet de donner dans les régions une
majorité pour agir parce que la
proportionnelle a évidemment cet
inconvénient que sinon elle laisse à un
groupe même s'il est minoritaire et
fonctionnel l'argent minoritaire mais
cette possibilité de faire la balance ce
qui est de l'inacceptable témoin je
combats le front national le front
national combat les libéraux j'entends
combattre le front national à ma façon
et je crois que le bon combat contre le
front national c'est pas l'ostracisme du
front national c'est pas ma stratégie
c'est le déballe le débat d idées
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'alliance
possible avec le front national c'est un
fait
eh bien nous en tirons les conséquences
mais simplement se tient quand même à
bien dire que dans cette affaire s'il ya
bien des gens qui ont intérêt
aujourd'hui avoir rétrécir un peu le
front national c'est nous et il ya eu en
revanche ceux qui ont intérêt à voir le
maintien du front national ne se sont
plutôt que le 11 juin là c'est pas une
question d'intérêt une formation c'est
une question de conviction vous dites
aujourd'hui a pas d'alliance possibles
bon ça laisse entendre que demain il ya
peut-être des alliances possibles
vous n'aurez jamais quelque chose de
peines allant jusqu'à je suis
délibérément définitivement est
entièrement contre le front national il
n'y a jamais d'alliance possibles avec
le troisième il ya toujours un combat
contre en chef on peut pas dire droite
qu'est ce que vous voulez mais moi je ne
peux pas accepter qu'on dise aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas d'alliance pcf le front
national ce qui laisse entendre que s'il
voulait bien tendre la main s'ils disent
la même chose qu'il vous plaise il
pourrait y avoir une allure et choses
sont claires le front national propose à
l'opposition un programme commun il
n'est pas question de programme commun
est d'accord avec le front national
simplement il faudra un jour qu'on se
pose la question est ce que monsieur
strauss kahn
vous ne souhaitez pas la réintégration
de toute une partie des électeurs
aujourd'hui qui sont stérilisés dans le
débat politique dans la vie nationale
est ce qu'il ya des conditions à poser
pour cela mais je crois qu'il faudra
qu'on se pose un jour ensemble
sérieusement cette question
non mais on va pas se la poser un jour
on se la pose tous les jours quand on
est comme moi et la banlieue parisienne
on rencontre les problèmes que pose le
front national dans toutes les cités et
faire reculer le front national c'est
mener le combat tous les jours c'est pas
se poser un jour la question mais ce que
je crois c'est que ça n'est pas en étant
proches du front national ce que vous
n'êtes pas besoin de là mais ce que
certains chez vous peuvent être en
disant on peut éventuellement un jour
avoir des alliances est le front
national qu'on le fait reculer on le
fait reculer le combattant sur les idées
et en le combattant sur le terrain il
n'y a pas d'autre voie mais la meilleure
façon de combattre le front national
c'est de ne pas lui apporter de grain à
moudre et quand je prends par exemple
cette mauvaise loi
ces mauvaises lois sur l'immigration que
votre gouvernement a fait voter à
l'assemblée nationale qui à mon avis
n'était pas urgente
il n'était pas nécessaire il aurait
mieux valu faire voter la bonne noah sur
l'exclusion peut-être en parlerons nous
mais lorsque d'une telle loi par exemple
vont de fait entraîné un nouveau flot de
régulation des immigrés clandestins
un nouveau flot de regroupement familial
et un nouveau flot d'immigration
clandestine parce qu'on leur a pour une
part dépénaliser l'entrée d'immigrés
clandestins la complicité à l'entrée des
mineurs clandestins
je trouve que de cette façon là vous
servez plus tôt la soupe au front
national face au ghana les lois que
auquel fait allusion sont soit très
équilibré qui ne favorise pas l'entrée
l'immigration clandestine mais je trouve
qu'il sorte de parangon de 60 lorsque
l'on dépénalise l'aide apportée par
quelqu'un un lointain membres de sa
famille à l'entrée irrégulière sur le
territoire national
c'était autrefois un délit pénal et l'on
risquait même le retrait de son titre de
séjour
ce n'est plus un délit pénal et on ne
risque plus le retrait de son titre de
séjour
lorsque l'on fait ça est ce que vous ne
pensez pas que l'on encourage ce qui est
un souci très légitime d'une famille
d'immigrés en situation régulière en
france que de pouvoir faire venir
clandestinement tel ou tel membre de sa
famille qui se trouvent dans une
difficile situation difficile en algérie
au mali où ailleurs normaux suel ce qui
a changé avec la nouvelle loi c'est
qu'en effet ce que monsieur debré avait
fait en 96 sans doute aviez-vous voté
pour c'est à dire de dépénaliser
l'accueil ascendants les descendants a
été étendue aux frères et soeurs vous
pouvez trouver que ce qui vaut pour les
parents et les enfants ne doit pas
valoir pour les frères et moi je
attendu beaucoup plus large non monsieur
strauss ya je pense que c'est une
mauvaise disposition de juin peut même
de même juste d'un mot de l'homme le
fait que aujourd'hui nous contrôlons il
nous régularisons a71 nombre d'immigrés
en situation irrégulière et un sur deux
ne sera pas régularisée le fait de les
tolérer
parce que c'est la situation aujourd'hui
sur le territoire national je crois que
c'est un mauvais service à rendre à la
cause de l'immigration régulière en
france
messieurs mesdames vous répondez juste
et enfin c'est le héros passe au d'abord
elle ne pouvait pas régulariser une
partie d'entre eux n'empêche pas que les
autres étaient déjà là quand vous étiez
au pouvoir donc ça change strictement
rien au nombre de gens qui sont sur le
territoire
donc a de ce point de vue là il vaut
mieux régulariser ce qu'on peut mais je
n'arrive pas à régler la risée les
autres que de faire semblant de faire
l'autruche et ne voir personne mais
quand ils sont contrôlés vrai venir au
début de votre père vous avez fait le
procès au gouvernement de dire il
fallait pas parler des migrations parce
que parler d'immigration c'est donner du
grain à moudre au front national
non on n'est pas distant non je suis
partisan de parler d'immigration mais il
ya un certain nombre de mesures que vous
avez mis dans la loi qui elles
nourrissent le front national vient vous
avez dit philippe avait relaté cette loi
sur l'exclusion oui comme je vous ai vue
de l'ouïe référendum sur l'immigration
j'ai l'impression que ce qui donne du
grain à moudre c'est plutôt vous at-elle
pas que monsieur douste-blazy dans le
monde quelques jours après ces crues de
voir alors vous critiquez vous expliquer
sur ce point vous expliquer sur ce point
monsieur strauss kahn répond tout aussi
brièvement et on passe aux points
suivants notamment sur à qui doit
profiter la nationalité française c'est
le bien précieux de tous les français
jaurès a commencé nos wii jaurès aussi
les pauvres n'ont que la patrie à partir
de ce moment là on peut toucher à la
nationalité française tout gouvernement
a le droit de le faire mais il doit le
faire dans le consensus c'est ce
qu'avait fait le précédent gouvernement
pour modifier les lois sur la
nationalité c'est ce que vous n'avez pas
fait et vous avez fait adopter une
modification du code de la nationalité
et notamment une disposition qui me
paraissait plutôt de bon sens c'est la
nationalité française ne se distribuer
pas il fallait la demande et pour
l'obtenir
et vous l'avez fait contre la volonté
des français mais nous voilà pourquoi
j'ai dit que si vous aviez si l'on avait
consulté les français par référendum il
aurait donné un tout autre vote et que
l'on aurait dû n'est pas exact que la
précédente modifications avaient été
faites dans consensus nous étions compte
peut-être que se considérer que ces
parties de la population qu'on doit
considérer mais nous étions mission
marceau long qui avait travaillé à
marceau de service vers une île au
consensus le plus large si on la paie
des familles spirituelles de sa
commission bart tommelein a b c a de
quoi bien testé que le poids des chirac
avait dû retirer le projet dont on
pensait alors tout cas la nouvelle
majorité a fait ce que j'ai bon secteur
jugent au monde c'est normal je crois
que ce texte à texte très équilibré et
qui a rétabli à son de choses qu'il
fallait rétablir qui étaient inhumaines
vis-à-vis de l'immigration tout en
durcissant d'autres peines par exemple
les passeurs clandestins ou alors peine
considérablement augmenté il faut à la
fois empêcher l'immigration clandestine
j'en suis tout à fait d'accord mais dans
le même temps traités humainement ce
qu'ils sont
un autre point maintenant puisque on en
reste là dessus on voit bien ce que sans
vos différences donc un autre point qui
est croissance économique
un monsieur madelin est ce qu'elle est
là grâce à qui à qui est ce qu elle doit
bénéficier
est-ce que je peux ajouter une question
oui est-ce qu'elle va de six essais sur
le même thème
oui parce qu'elle intéresse tous les
françaises qu'elle va durer acquis
d'hôtel bénéficier alors est ce qu'elle
est là oui si vous m'aviez posé la
question il y a un an
elle m'a été posée de la croissance elle
est de retour
il ya de grandes chances que ce soit une
croissance durable pour la raison
essentielle que la france tiré le profit
de l'effort d'assainissement financier
qui avait été engagé avant vous que vous
avez poursuivi c'est bien et qui a
permis une détente monétaire une baisse
des taux d'intérêt et des conditions de
croissance et que la france également
était tirée par ses exportations
d'un côté la hausse du dollar des pays
qui était en plein boom et qui tiraient
les exportations françaises
la question qui se pose si l'on me pose
la question aujourd'hui est ce que cela
va durer
je crains que dans et je ne donne
rendez-vous à monsieur strauss kahn vers
la fin de l'année ce que la croissance
ce qu'il annonce sera au rendez vous la
croissance voyez vous c'est le résultat
de ce qui est fait douze mois dix-huit
mois plus tôt pour moi les indicateurs
avancés d'une croissance saine et
durable dans ce pays ce serait une vraie
reprise de l'investissement ou une vraie
reprise de la création d'entreprise
je souhaite que cela arrive mais cela
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui monsieur
strauss kahn je comprend l'embarras
monsieur mais demain la croissance et
quand on l'a fait qu'elle est là et si
vous aviez pensé monsieur madela il ya
un an que la croissance serait de retour
on ne riait pas dissout ou de proposer
opposant la république de dissoudre si
vous aviez pensé que vous aviez semer et
que vous alliez recueillir les fruits
vous auriez attendu pour les recueillir
avant les élections à londres tout le
monde sait très bien que la majorité
passer aujourd'hui l'opposition a
dissout pas ce qu'elle voyait un avenir
tellement difficile des finances
publiques
insupportable qu'elle allait dans le mur
et c'est pour ça qu'elle a voulu
dissoudre en se disant on règlera les
problèmes après vous ne croyez magrin tu
me voyais pas du tout à l'époque à la
croissance et la réalité c'est que la
politique qui a été conduite depuis neuf
mois a soutenu la croissance lorsqu'on à
augmenter le smic au mois de juillet ça
a servi la consommation lorsqu'à la
rentrée l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
a été quadruplé ça a aidé à la
consommation l'ensemble des mesures qui
ont été prises en matière budgétaire ont
aidé à la consommation et la
consommation a été de retour quand la
consommation était de retour
l'investissement démarre et toutes les
enquêtes montrent ça doit vous rassurer
puisque c'est l'investissement qui vous
intéressent qu'il va revenir quand je
disais depuis plusieurs semaines
peut-être plusieurs mois nous allons
avoir froid 2% de croissance en 98 on
disait ah oui dis ça parce que c'est son
rôle de ministre des finances mais en
fait il n'y croit pas et puis depuis
quinze jours plus personne ne dise ne
dis ça n'a pas existé on dit qu'est ce
que vous allez faire avec tout cet
argent
le pessimisme était exagéré mais
l'optimisme aussi aujourd'hui d'être
exagéré
la croissance est de retour elle va
faire du pouvoir d'achat elle va créer
des emplois on voit d'ailleurs que le
chômage baisse depuis octobre
ça va continuer vous m'avez donné rendez
vous à la fin de l'année est bien
d'accord
à la fin de l'année nous verrons si nous
avons eu 3 % de croissance nous aurons
eu 3 3% de croissance 2% pouvoir d'achat
un chômage qui baisse et si la confiance
revient dans ce pays c'est bien parce qu
une politique différente
été pendues depuis neuf mois je
m'appelle d'une phrase vous avez
prononcé au moment de la dissolution
vous disiez ça sert à rien de la
dissolution si c'est pas pour changer de
politique vous rappeler d'avoir dit çà
vous voyez il ya une dissolution n'a
changé de politique et les choses vont
mieux s'il ya des solutions c'est pas
pour des raisons budgétaires ou pour des
problèmes de croissance
je crois que tout le monde est d'accord
pour penser que la croissance était
enfin de revenus en tout cas moi je le
disais et j'y croyais mais justement
comment fallait-il accompagner ce retour
de la croissance
moi j'étais effectivement partisans
d'une politique un peu différente et
d'accompagner ce retour de la croissance
par un certain nombre de réformes de
structure libérant l'initiative des
créateurs d'entreprises des petites
entreprises susceptibles vraiment
d'avoir ce retour d'investissement et
c'était l'autre preneur yal dont le pays
a besoin
bon ça n'a pas marché ça n'a pas marché
vous êtes au gouvernement tant mieux
pour vous mais j'observe aujourd'hui que
les scènes avancé de la croissance pour
l'avenir ne sont pas là est ce que
monsieur et monsieur strauss kahn je
vous donne effectivement rendez vous on
verra d'ici à la fin de l'année la
croissance continue ou si elle est en
train de taguer on verra ce soir et vous
êtes contents de ce que nous dira de
voir que toutes les enquêtes auprès des
chefs d'entreprise des petites et
moyennes entreprises annonce une
croissance formidable de
l'investissement pas les grandes et les
petites et les moyennes celles qui
généra je suis très content monsieur
strauss kahn mais je n'oublie pas que
les mêmes enquêtes annonce est un retour
de l'investissement 1996
vous l'avez résultat avait cassé le
résultat a été neuf fois inférieure ce
que vous la prévision celui penser c'est
ou quatre ans 1997 cette fois inférieurs
et que l'on annonce depuis longtemps le
retour de l'investissement et que je ne
vois pas et que des mesures comme par
exemple les 35 heures c'est une mesure
qui prend de front les entreprises et
particulièrement les petites et moyennes
entreprises qui ne comprennent
absolument pas cette histoire de partage
autoritaire du travail sont de nature à
casser la confiance est donc affaire à
300 mais non si c'était vrai nous
n'aurions pas aujourd'hui la croissance
et la confiance si vous aviez raison que
je vais être honnête et vous pourriez
avoir raison vous avez réussi en effet à
casser en 96 comment 87 femmes ou ceux
qui étaient au gouvernement mais que
vous souteniez ont réussi à casser la
reprise la croissance a souvent là
aujourd'hui nous avons mais ça qui est
formidable c'est que contrairement à ce
que vous dites avec un texte les 35
heures dont on dit qu'il est patron n'en
veulent pas mais quand on les rencontre
individuellement ils savent bien
que c'est quelque chose qui va leur
permettre la négociation dans
l'entreprise contrairement à ce que vous
agiter comme épouvantail
on voit que la confiance est là ça se
voit dans les sondages ça se voit dans
les consommations ça sera un chiffre
d'affaires vous êtes interview au bild à
des vérifications
monsieur strauss kahn je trouve vraiment
formidable parce que vous êtes presque
convaincant malheureusement lorsque l'on
regarde les chiffres d'un peu plus près
vous parler du retour de la consommation
en janvier dernier 10 novembre des
sommets non au dernier trimestre la
consommation a baissé monsieur social se
mettre au dernier trimestre la
consommation et sur l'a10 à deux
chiffres la croissance économique est
sur une pente de trois et demi pour son
père pas de l'année 90 sièges auto n'a
pas vu ça depuis cette journée vous on
n'a pas vu ça depuis cinq ans et vous
nous dites se demande à tous les
observateurs et tous les journalistes
économiques sérieux de regarder de
demain dans la presse de dire si j'ai eu
tort ou si j'ai raison de dire que la
consommation avait diminué
je trouvais pour faire voir si oui ou
non il ya une super je dis oui on
termine et c'est que les 35 heures sont
vraiment une erreur économique profond
quand on sait qu en ce seul et que c'est
sur ces mesures là qui sont les mesures
structurelles que vous avez engagé que
l'on vous jugera donc les mois et les
années qui viennent cela ne créera pas
les emplois que vous avez promis
cela va créer un renchérissement du coût
du travail au niveau du smic est
peut-être la chose la plus grave
à mes yeux c'est que cela va provoquer
dans les années qui viennent un gel des
salaires des goûters vous dit tout ça
parce que vous l'avez toujours dit donc
j'en ai aujourd'hui quand les 35 heures
ont créé des emplois
vous aurez l'honnêteté de dire je me
suis trompé un rendez vous dans un an
rendez-vous dans un an le strauss kahn
s'il la création d'emplois marche par la
diminution de la durée du travail si
cela est vrai vous avez inventé une
machine formidable et 6 35 heures créer
cinq cent mille emplois
alors il ne faudra pas s'arrêter là il
faudra faire 30 heures nous faire un
million d'emplois 25 millions cinq cent
mille emplois et à 15 heures il ya plus
de chemins non
voyez comme vous faites de la propagande
et pas de l'économie semaine la personne
ne dit qu'il force qu'il faut continuer
comme ça ya un an il faut les appliquer
la fonction publique un moment donné ils
les appliquer le fait que les élections
aient lieu
comment allait trancher mais à un moment
donné dans une économie à une durée du
travail qui convient à la productivité
et au progrès technique
aujourd'hui dans notre pays 35 heures
est une bonne chose pour les entreprises
qu'ils peuvent tout ne peuvent pas est
certaine le ferons car nous d'autre part
dans les autres pays
mais regardez regardez aux pays bas le
temps de travail ps maintenant aux
pays-bas vous avez quelque chose qui est
tout à fait différent c'est la
flexibilité du temps de travail la
liberté contractuelle alors vive la
liberté contractuelle du temps de
travail non à la réduction autoritaire
et en avant des slogans fait des choses
vous avez été au pouvoir pendant dérivés
vous n'avez pas fait cette fameuse
flexibilité dont vous parlez tout il n'y
a aucun pays au monde et même aucun
dirigeant socialiste en europe qui sans
rien dans la même direction j'en ai
assez de cette exception from si c'est
vrai yao k il n'y a aucun pays en europe
dont le tueur ne tente pas une baisse
pas c'est vrai qu'ils ne baissent pas
par une loi
ils baissent spontanément la négociation
a lieu spontanément dans le pays n'a pas
lieu
nous disons très bien nous mettons en
place des incitations ceux qui veulent
le fond vous savez les 35 heures ce
n'est pas obligatoire c'est la durée
légale
aujourd'hui ces 39 eur et les
entreprises qui trahit plus s'il vous
est ce qui t'arrive moi vous savez très
bien
35 heures de la même manière n'est pas
du tout une baisse autoritaire on fait
semblant de le dire c'est une incitation
à l'est vers 35 heures avec des aides
pour y aller et c'est typiquement une
mesure incitative les entreprises qui ne
voudront pas devront payer des heures
supplémentaires celles qui voudront y
aller non pas à payer les heures
supplémentaires c'est une incitation
financière sanaryens autoritaire et
c'est pour ça que ça va marcher et vous
aurez beau très beau joueur ou leur nom
et ses cinq heures payées 39 au niveau
10 mx est une erreur monumentale que
l'on paiera par un chômage aggravé de
l'amateur humery belle blonde est alors
oui mais pas grâce aux forces de
sécurité de ne pas briser cette
croissance par une perte de confiance
alors il ya une chance de bien poser une
question
avant le débat qui aura lieu l'année
prochaine à la fin de l'année entre vous
comptez sur nous pour l'organiser elles
sont peu demandées dominique strauss
kahn s'il ya fruits de la croissance que
weezy de croissance donc fruits comment
on fait comment on répare pas qui on
donne
il n'y a qu'une seule manière de briser
la croissance et ce qui s'est passé en
96 quand deux points de tva ont été
rajoutés ont cassé la croissance je
crois me rappeler vous étiez de miser
finances qui avait préparé la loi de
finances pour 81 ans est décédé monsieur
strauss père aujourd'hui décédé
c'est ce que je constate c'est qu'à
l'époque vous avez cassé la croissance à
nous l'avons accompagné c'est pour ça
qu'elle est la marque est aussi je dis
pas resté très longtemps au gouvernement
c'est peut être posée parce que j'avais
quelques désaveux peut-être que je suis
pas d'accord avec monsieur juppé je
voulais un acte alors en tout cas pour
qui la croissance pour les salariés par
le pouvoir d'achat pour les chômeurs par
l'emploi et pour les exclus grâce à la
loi que martine aubry l'a pas encore
fait voter elle annoncé hier qu'il fera
voter dans quelques semaines il ya trois
objectifs l'emploi l'emploi l'emploi le
gouvernement ne va que dans une seule
direction l'emploi pour ceux qui sont
chômeurs l'emploi pour ceux qui ont du
mal à laisser marcher travail qu'il faut
former et qui n'iront ce marché travail
qu'au bout d'un certain moment et le
soutien par solidarité pour ceux qui
malheureusement parce qu'ils sont trop
âgés ou ils sont au chômage depuis trop
longtemps ils ont des handicaps ils ont
des difficultés à venir marché du
travail ont besoin d'être soutenus les
fruits de la croissance
diront dans cette direction là il
commence dit elle est déjà puisque du
pouvoir d'achat est déjà distribuée et
des créations d'emplois existent dans
déjà rien n'est jamais facile ça ne se
fera pas en cinq minutes mais si je
crois que c'est le cas les neuf mois qui
viennent ici la fin de l'année sont les
mêmes les neuf fois que nous venons de
vivre
alors nous aurons fin 98 chômage sera
franchement baissé le franchement pour
ampli mais si l'on dit emploi emploi
emploi
un exemple il ya une étude récente les
qui vient de paraître et qui nous montre
que si nous avions le même taux d'emploi
dans l'hôtellerie la restauration et le
commerce que les états unis nous aurions
deux millions huit cent mille emplois en
plus c'est dire que
les emplois des petites entreprises il y
à de véritables freins et yeux le projet
que je souhaite depuis longtemps pour
mon pays c'est la vrai projet qui
consiste à mobiliser 2 millions
d'emplois par les petites entreprises
qui est insolent sont créatrices
d'emplois or justement je crois que les
mesures qui sont prises comme les 35
heures et puis toute une série d'autres
mesures autoritaires sont de nature à
briser là la confiance et à ne pas
pouvoir tirer parti de ce dynamisme des
petites entreprises dans notre pays et
je crois que ces mesures-là prépare bien
et le mal l'avenir de la france et que
la politique que vous menez ne portera
pas toutes les chances que vous nous
avons heureusement que les pâtes rendre
positive le contraire non monsieur sauce
gaz et voyez bien les indications alors
messieurs les blindages et vous
connaissez le patron d'une petite
entreprise artisanale qui vous explique
comment il va appliquer les 35 heures
autorités à son entreprise nouvelle la
blessure de dernière minute qui nous
reste pour les deux dernières minutes
qui nous reste on voudrait que l'un
comme l'autre vous nous disiez pas
forcément en substance ce que vous
proposez en matière de sécurité pour
améliorer les choses
quand on a été maire d'une ville de
banlieue dans la banlieue parisienne on
sait que la question la sécurité c'est
une question premier avant même parfois
de la préoccupation des gens avant même
le chômage parce que c'est tout à fait
inadmissible tous les jours de voir son
fils rentrer en sept ans fait voler son
imperméable se voir sa voiture cassée le
matin même ceux qui sont les moins
répressifs finissent au bout d'un moment
par dire c'est plus supportable si bien
qu'il faut absolument que l' équilibre
entre ceux qui avaient pression qui est
nécessaire et ce qu'ils récession soit
parfaitement tenu à villepinte jean
pierre chevènement a tenu il ya de ça
quelques mois colloque qui a défini
notre politique de sécurité et qui tient
ces deux aspects à la fois une
répression sans faille quand c'est
nécessaire et à la fois autant
d'accompagnement et de réinsertion qu'il
est possible et les emplois jeunes par
exemple vont directement dans ce sens là
dans ma ville par exemple il ya 120
emplois jeunes qui ont été embauchés
depuis qu'ils ont été mis en place
ces 120 jeunes garçons et jeunes filles
plutôt des garçons des filles d'ailleurs
en majorité qui étaient dans la rue qui
ne faisait rien dont certains ont
inévitablement tournés vers la
délinquance et qui aurait continué quoi
qu'on fasse
si on trouvait pas le moyen de leur
fournir quelque chose à faire les
emplois jeunes leur fournisse 6 partout
en france
la tâche d'huile se fait comme elle est
enfin de se faire sais pas combien vous
en avez monsieur mais de là dans votre
ville mais si partout en france cela se
fait comme ça se fait dans beaucoup de
villes en tout cas celle que je connais
un bon bonne partie des questions de
sécurité seront réglés il n'y a pas que
les jeunes soient l'origine des
problèmes de sécurité mais il ya
notamment dans la banlieue les problèmes
que posent les jeunes et nous apportons
à une solution à la pression est aussi
appuyé et les néracais
il y à une montée dramatique de la
délinquance et de la délinquance des
jeunes aujourd'hui et notamment de plus
en plus jeunes et à partir de 7-8 ans
c'est ce que disent les forces de police
sur le terrain
personne n'a la solution et je crois
qu'il faut être les uns et les autres
modèles simplement on sait maintenant je
crois les uns et les autres qu'il faut
changer d'appproche notamment en ce qui
concerne la délinquance juvénile et qu'
il y avait une tendance à vieillir à
excuser la première délinquants sont
durs et circonstances le social que
sais-je encore on verra ça la prochaine
fois et qu'il faut avoir une attitude
beaucoup plus rude et les pays qui ont
cette attitude plus répressives
même si en même temps il faut bien sûr
accompagné sa démesure éducatrices ont
tous sont aujourd'hui des pays qui
réussissent à faire reculer la sécurité
mais je crois qu'il faut appeler un chat
un chat
lorsqu'un certain nombre de maires il y
a quelques mois constatons qu'il y avait
des jeunes de 8 ans qui traînait à 3
heures du matin dans les quartiers la
délinquance ont décidé de faire un
couvre feu pour les jeunes ce qui était
lui-même souhaité par les parents pour
renforcer l'autorité parentale qu'est ce
que l'on a dit on a refusé vous avez
refusé ce a rejeté sa avec mépris
vous avez mis votre collègue du
gouvernement ségolène royal qui a dit
les enfants ne sont pas des chiens
monsieur tony blair a fait ça quelques
temps plus tard et lorsque la seule
chose que vous allez proposer c'est
d'imposer un couvre feu non pas aux
jeunes mais à la police municipale
je crois qu'il faudra une phase i en
connaître dernièrement pour rendre
crédible votre volonté de sécurité ça
sera votre dernier mot
merlin merci à tous les deux rendez vous
à tous les deux aussi évidemment le 15
mars soir des résultats des élections
régionales dans un instant envoyé
spécial demain 20h vous retrouverez
béatrice schönberg
merci
je vous retrouve